from mental health to academic
performance there is clearly a link in
tonight kate houston
taking a look at a report that
illustrates how suffering students
can translate to suffering grades this
week ccsd released a 20 page report part
of which highlighted the low grades many
students received last semester
some parents tell me this is not normal
for their kids
the report's cards came home with c's
and
f's rachel maxwell is a mom of four
while some of her kids are doing okay
with online learning
her third grader went from a consistent
a student to struggling with his grades
you see how it wears down on them and
him especially i'm watching
it's concerning a report from ccsd shows
90 percent of schools assigned more
f grades last semester than the year
before 11 percent of students who
received an f
in fall of 2020 earned all a's and b's
in fall of 2019.
this doesn't work for him he wants to
separate school from home
kimberly peterson says her high school
senior connor went from a weighted 4.3
gpa at the start of the semester
to earning below a 3.0 he'll complete
something
turn it in think he did great on it
and not get even close to the grade that
he was expecting
in addition to losing the social aspect
of school peterson says her son's grades
are hurting due to the lack of personal
interactions with teachers
there's moments in the classroom that no
one ever anticipates
that become teachable that kids might
learn a lot from and all that's been
taken away the report also highlights
the impact on minority students
nearly 50 percent of black students
received at least one f on the latest
report card for native american and
hispanic students
it was nearly 45 percent a lot of them
are having to take care of their
siblings and help their siblings with
school
a lot of them have full-time jobs i have
a lot of students that are logging into
my classes from work
jamie anderson is encouraging parents to
be in close contact with teachers
saying many grading problems can be
solved together over the phone or email
this report will be presented to the
school board on thursday to discuss
potentially bringing kids back into the
classroom
kate houston 8 news now of course we
will carry thursday's meeting live
district staff
is recommending only small groups return
on a voluntary basis
and they have no timetable for a more
structured return
of course the hybrid plan is still up
for consideration as well
we will have full coverage right here on
8newsnow.com